[Música]
hola andrés televidente los saludos
desde casa
la sede principal de la liga de
gobernantes anticorrupción hacia donde
están llegando poco a poco los
seguidores de rodolfo hernández es
ingeniero de 77 años que aspira a la
presidencia de colombia con ello se
llega también la lluvia eso
a cambio estado bastante lluvioso el día
funcionando entonces
la realidad es que es su departamento de
nacimiento de santander en donde están
habilitadas serán agotadas 17 millones
de personas en este roedor fernández es
conocido en esta región por haber
saneado las finanzas de la ciudad de
bucaramanga la capital de santander
cuando fue alcalde en el período
comprendido entre 2016 y 2019 también
por declararse una persona antisistema y
por su discurso contra la corrupción
pese a que el próximo 21 de julio tiene
que responder ante las autoridades
dentro de un juicio por corrupción en
todo caso pues el 66% de las personas
salieron a votar en primera vuelta en
este departamento de santander y ya
veremos entonces cómo le va en esta
ocasión a rodolfo donde se encuentra el
candidato permanecerá en su casa a la
espera de los resultados como sucedió
durante la primera vuelta
[Música]
puede ser el candidato salió muy
temprano a votar a las ocho en punto de
la mañana estaba en el colegio santander
ubicado a pocos kilómetros de esta su
sede de campaña y de ahí se dirigió
directamente hasta su casa ubicada en el
municipio de piedecuesta que está a unos
20 kilómetros de la capital de santander
su equipo de comunicaciones nos ha
informado que las únicas declaraciones
que hará serán a través de su equipo de
comunicaciones que está en su casa y por
vía twitter desde donde ya se pronunció
en varias ocasiones sobre la jornada
electoral y uno de suscribiros estaba
dirigido directamente a su contrincante
el criticó a gustavo petro por haber
lanzado ciertas denuncias sobre presunto
fraude electoral en todo caso se ha
dicho que sea cual sea el resultado
rodolfo hernández estará viéndolo desde
su casa y aquí sus seguidores lo estarán
viendo desde casa nariño en una tarima
especial que está haciendo en este
momento construida a mis espaldas para
mostrar los resultados en vivo y en
directo